hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we're gonna show from the final
round of the 2019 isle of man chess
tournament it's 11 ariane versus magnus
carlsen and it's well a lot is at stake
here not only great you know standings
to the tournament but also 11 shot at
the candidates tournament so we're not
gonna dwell too long on it we do have
one photo of this event here it is
nope that's just dink sipping on his
water here it is I just have to I
haven't prepared it so let me just
resize that for a bit we do have a very
nice handshake here there you have it
the handshake before the the start of
the game Elevens d4 is already on the
board you can see Magnus holding a bag
of goodies there on the right and also
the gentleman behind him we were ready
to you know scan for any suspicious
activity you know on end of the board so
that being said let's check out the game
and also I would just like to mention
today is Maxime Pasha holographs and
birthday so if you run into him you know
in a bar or a library make sure you
congratulate him so without further ado
let's check out the game eleven the
width of the white pieces opens with d4
and will Knight to f6 by Magnus c4 e6
Knight to c3 and not the Queens gambit
declined but rather the nimzo-indian we
have Bishop to b4 f3 now by eleven the
more variation and now c5 we have d5
advancing in the center and now b5
trying to get white to capture here to
loosen his grip on the center but of
course white is not interested in that
Levin goes he for and now d6 by Magnus
with brush up to d2 and now there are a
couple of moves that have been played
here a six is a known move B captures in
c4 is a known move reach of the rockwork
to play the e capture son d5 against
charter in Mahmud II Arvin the st. Louis
rapid tournament now we've covered that
game I believe and he won a very nice
game but here because of Kafiristan c3
by Magnus is a new move so already as a
move seven we have a completely new game
with the shop characters and now across
and just advances the b-pawn before I
get rid of the bishop from this very
nice diagonal the shabak the D to end
now cross and castles Bishop returns the
e3 now 11 was
the Queen via the D 2 square and now II
capture Sun d5 of course you don't want
to open up the center as your king is
still in the middle of the board so seek
after Sun d5 and now Knight F to d7 sort
of a bit of an unprincipled move playing
with the same piece twice in the opening
as you have a lot of pieces undeveloped
on the Queen side but with good reason
xi king is still is still in the center
of the board so you want to play f5 bust
open the center get your rook a nice
open or at least a semi open file to use
for attacking purposes so Knight to e2
by 11 and now f5 preparing to capture on
e4 we have a cat person f5 rook captures
on f5 and now knife to g3 pushing
Magnus's look back look the if I'm not
pinning the bishop and King to F do now
unpinning and also defending in the
bishop on e3 with Queen to h4 by Magnus
now you know things are definitely
happening on the board and 11 goes for
Queen to d2 and Knight to f6 so you can
see that it can get a little unpleasant
for white for example not at the moment
but if this rook was for example and I
fade Knights the 94 check would win the
Queen at the pond will not be able to
capture the the knight is also pin so
you will not be able to capture not
possible at the moment but if you give a
Magnus a move or two it could get very
ugly for white so rook the c1 here 11
once rook the c4 he wants to kick away
crossings Queen from such a nice square
bishop the ACE is by Magnus not allowing
it or also offering a trade of light
square bishop saw a bunch of characters
Knight captures then cost and we can
very quickly get the rook into the game
like we discussed
and now b3 by 11 preparing ideas like
Bishop to c4 or or maybe something else
and here the situation on the clock is
at one minute one hour and six minutes
for 11 and 46 minutes for Magnus so
magnus definitely taking his time here
and here he played Knight captures on d5
I know you guys are wondering if this is
a free pawn you could capture with the
rook or with the night so it's
interesting what happens if rook
captures if rook captures the Queen is
under attack Queen to be two now you
trade bishops Bishop captures rook
captures and now Knight
six and you will get your rook to c4
move and now comes Knight to d4 and we
get this crazy position that I think
it's impossible to evaluate from the
position before anything even starts
so Magnus avoids it and instead he goes
for Knight captures on d5 which is it
offers a lot of play for example what
can you play here here there is this
idea of bishop characters on c5 it seems
like a very tricky move the rook
captures pawn captures rook captures now
threatening as you just capture two
points to also win back your piece but
black has Queen to d8 guarding the pawn
regarding tonight and now Bishop to c4
at just you know pinning the attacked
piece basically not allowing the the
knight move but also the night couldn't
move because the Queen would be hanging
on da so here a bunch of characters pawn
captures and it seems like like now you
are winning the piece back because then
I still cannot move problem is black has
Queen to b6 and now you don't have a
good move
now the rook will fall with check or you
can play Queen to d4 and now Knight to
c6 comes again you don't have a move
there's there's just nothing to play
here the the Queen has to move you are
out of useful squares from where you can
guard the rook that's just a game over
so after this Knight captures on d5 you
also might consider rook to e1 but you
already place the rook and c1 level and
really wants to get this rook over to c4
at some point but it it is an
interesting line but after Knight
captures and e3 rook captures you get
Queen to d4 and now everything just gets
straight as Queen captures pawn captures
rook captures on e5 d captures and
Bishop captures and a6 with Knight
captures and rook will come to the only
open file on the board rook to c1 and
the Carson would be up upon but 11 at
least gets the the open follow for his
rook so an equal position but 11 once
more he plays rook to c4 now tries to
give up the exchange but not really the
route cannot be captured if rook
captures Bishop captures in there
there's just no saving this Knight
you don't only lose the night but after
you capture this this comes with check
you could also lose the rook here so it
would be completely winning for Levin so
after loop the c-4 Carlsen goes back we
have Queen to e7
putting additional pressure on the
bishop here and the now
looked for blocking this attack with
Queen East six by Magnus now also adding
another defender to the knight on d5 and
here comes a Bishop to f4 now forcing
the trade with Knight captures an F for
Queen captures on f4 and now Bishop
captures on f1 here you don't you don't
capture right away because if rook
captures then you get Knight to d7 in
and then you get additional control over
the e5 square so here we have roof
characters on 85 by 11 and now the
situation on the clock is at 43 minutes
eleven twenty eight minutes Carlson with
D captures on e5 and now Queen t4 by by
11 Knight to c6 as the rook is under
attack
finally the knight is developed the
route can also come into the game and
now rook captures Ani on f1 and there
was no time to save the bishop and we
have a c4 here so what do you do here
Carlson finds a very nice idea he plays
in Knight to f5 there's an there's no
need to do anything rash on the Queen
side you could cap for a pawn sure you
could go B captures here but that just
ruins your pawn structure and black will
just continue development if Queen
captures it's not a problem
cross and decided to give a give this
pawn back but 11 finds a nice - f5 and
it's a it's an even better idea because
C capture son b3 and the cross and
really had to calculate this he plays C
capture son b3 and of course do you see
what Levin's idea was here why did he
allow such such a move
I'm sure you could recap from b3 right
away but Levin's idea is Queen captures
in c6 of course you have to capture
Queen captures on c6 and the now Knight
to e7 check and it seems like 11:1 a
piece and in fact he did but Carson has
a passed pawn so King to f8 Knight
captures queen and now B captures on a2
so threatening nothing for a moment but
if you can get to this point pushing
then it will be very good for black so
Knight character some before and now why
did cousin allow this how does cross an
unwind here you're you're down a piece
if the a two point is captured you're
just lost so feel free to positive
and try to find the only good move for
Magnus in this position while I give you
a couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on finding the only move that doesn't
lose and for those who just want to
enjoy the show
rook to b8 this is the idea rook to d8
with the same idea that if Knight
captures you're gonna go rook to d2
doesn't work because if rook to d8 then
just kink the e3 and there's never a
Ruby to d2 move so rook to b8 is much
better because it comes with an attack
on the night so congratulations to
everyone we have looked a 1 if you
capture then we already mention if you
capture Ruby to check King move you're
gonna capture here and Carson is just up
upon and it's it's it's even a past
eight point so the only one with the
winning chances will be crossing here so
after Luke the bid we have looked a 111
decides to give the knight back this way
rook captures on b4 we have rook
captures on a2 and now rook back to b7
guarding the a 7 point so Magnus up a
pawn with King to III into e 7 and after
rook t6 it was in this position and
moved 34 that 11 and Magnus agreed to a
draw so neither of them will be winning
this tournament and it's hard to say if
this will be enough for 11 to get his
spot in the candidates everything
depends on I believe how long how
finishes his game against David Howell
because a one cow has the the best
rating performance and there will be no
you know rapid or blitzed I break so it
will just be you know the final round is
over and that's it we just decide who
gets the spot in the candidates so we're
gonna know more after some more games
finish this this game finished very
early so I decided to show it as it was
it was a really interesting idea that
rook to c4 moved by 11 and well the
entire approach on how to take it out
Magnus but Magnus took it took his time
and defended it very well so once again
I do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank mikaël dinner for a conversion to
my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the show calm
I love Manchester namond continuing to
check up on your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world thank you I will see you soon and
heaven
rest of your day